and you're like hey yeah I know I know
there's construction I heard it again
bugged me you just trying to take a
pause for the construction for the
sounds of construction
it stopped it's alright I'm sure it's
finished yeah sure it's done yeah
construction is still happening it's
right it feels like it's all around me I
can't tell if it's right above my head
or right below me but yep it's still
happening and it's driving me crazy is
that the show wait okay boys op there's
construction again so you know I can't
judge anybody that is following this guy
but I don't care who the [ __ ] you have
to call stop the hammering I don't know
why these Keys gonna think it's gonna be
forever I'm in purgatory
this is bother here it's bothering me a
lot yeah you know that sound in the
black mirror intro right before the
glass shatters that that's what it is
it's like I'm waiting for black mirror
to start eternally just shatter the
glass to start the show you here at Troy
oh yeah yeah Travis comment I don't mind
it at all Valerie could you hang on a
second yeah I think they're [ __ ] with
me now there's literal hammering going
on do you hear that I didn't hear it
you heard it cuz you were smiling at me
because you knew that I was gonna hear
it they're literally hammering on what
sounds like empty aluminum pipes you
know so when you hammer the sound of it
it just echoes throughout that's what
they're doing now do you hear these
noises yeah of course I do Jim
and I know that you hear them too yeah
yeah this duct work being done I think
so I think that there is and even though
it's going on mr. button even though
it's going on downstairs now I was
scrolling through pages easy ways that
where it is downstairs people are saying
it's downstairs but then I find out that
that might be ours too all right
it may be SiriusXM construction
happening no yeah I mean dude you kind
of quit can i watch I just want to go
home can I go home that's the loudest
it's ever been yeah that is insane we're
doing a remote on the street it makes no
since I leave dude they're [ __ ] with
me now I feel like I'm a schizophrenic
and they're [ __ ] with my the voices
in my head are [ __ ] with me
there must be moving down the floor
because last week it was down there no I
heard him right under me last week all
week you all week yeah did you hear how
loud that last one was the loudest one
yet that's the loudest one Wow can I go
ahead strike
sounds like the building is hungry let's
try a lawnmower why you'll make all that
noise one more Jim and Sam catch up with
full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM a/v